one of the exciting things that
Yellowjackets season 2 episode 4 does is
ask us to consider how much of what we
believe about what's happening is based
on assumptions the role of cult leader
is one that brings some baggage along
with it into your thinking process
seeing someone preside over a
cannibalistic ritual wearing deer
antlers projects a type of vibe but is
it not possible that the surface level
reaction might not feel as
all-encompassing after more information
comes to light I liked how the end of
episode 2 and most of episode 3 made me
think about how we remember things and
how experience influences the stories we
tell ourselves I mentioned in my preview
video for episode 4 that the title Old
Wounds pretty much applies to everyone
involved in the 96 timeline and the
episode continues asking good questions
but this time focused more on how
experiences shape how we see others or
what we want to believe we see this
through teen lottie's face as it
connects all of these thoughts right
after Mari declares that she doesn't
need a gun to bring back food and again
when she puts her hand on the symbol and
then shakes her head like she has no
idea what she's doing this episode also
felt like it promised something that I
hope it can live up to when Shauna
confessed that she killed Adam to her
daughter I wholeheartedly agree with
Jeff's first impression that making your
teenage daughter an accomplice is a
terrible thing to do but this stands out
more for how it contrasts with her not
wanting to reveal what they did in the
wilderness because of their shame it's
not new information Nat did the same
thing in what you presume is a safe
space at rehab in the first episode Ty
wouldn't do it for the Shady political
backer and Misty wouldn't tell Jessica
but this feels like it underlines that
we haven't seen the worst of things yet
and that feels fitting as we watch the
tensions mounting inside the cabin the
last time it was um
became something different can't happen
again
just about everything in this episode
felt like it was moving in the right
direction even though it gets harder to
know if things are what they seem or how
some of these things are even happening
case in point how is sleepwalking tie
going straight to trees that are marked
with the symbol this isn't random and
it's not easy to come up with a rational
explanation that doesn't involve her
following the no-eyed Man Band says
something in you knows these trees are
here and that's a fair assumption based
on what she's seen of course Tai has no
interest in accepting that and gets
combative when she brings up the idea of
talking to Lottie about it so we know Ty
would prefer not to think about it at
all while van isn't willing to let the
idea go and that's something that we'll
get back to toward the end of the
episode in the present day we see Ty go
to Jessica Robert's apartment and get
the file that she put together for her
on the surviving Yellow Jackets it's a
little confusing because we see both
versions of Tai walking around but as
far as you can tell the bad tie is the
one making thing things happen right up
until she wakes up on the side of the
road and her assistant's car apparently
the bad one was so focused on getting
them to Oberlin Ohio that she forgot to
fuel up it's shot in a disorienting way
but it looks like she just leaves the
car there with the keys and folder
inside luckily after she walks for a
while she gets picked up by a truck
driver who knew her because he voted for
her you might think she would want to
leverage that to have him take her for a
gas can and then back to the car but
instead she just bonds with him over his
nudie pen and their shared appreciation
for the naked female form he gets her to
her destination dropping her off at a
retro video store called while you were
streaming this seems like a direct
callback to band talking about the 90s
movie While You Were Sleeping around the
campfire and that we saw Misty watching
on VHS with Jessica Roberts in her
basement hostage area
Van Works in the shop that looks cool
but is also not the kind of place you're
probably getting rich from owning
there's a lot of interesting stuff
everywhere and the sign behind her
having Mean Girls and Into the Wild on
the same line is a nice touch we don't
get much time with these two together in
this episode but Van's reaction to
seeing her walk in says a lot it takes
her a while to recognize her and Laura
Ambrose does a great job of showing that
as it's happening there's almost a vague
familiarity then recognition followed by
a brief smile and then a rush of emotion
that doesn't appear to be especially
Pleasant for me this says that they
haven't seen each other in years and
that it's unlikely that Tai would have
gone looking for her if the bad one
hadn't pushed her to I imagine that
since van knows about the sleepwalking
in the past Ty thinks she might be able
to help her make it stop also I think
it's worth clarifying that I use the
term bad one because that's how our son
Sammy referred to sleepwalking tie in
season one The more we see of this
entity the more complicated their
connection seems to be as is probably
the case with tying band's feelings
about each other since they broke up
we'll have to wait until next week to
find out more though the adult Shauna
stuff still feels a little disconnected
from everything else that's going on but
things are happening with the sedakis
the family actually feels Closer by the
end of the episode but they're all still
keeping secrets from each other Shawna
doesn't tell the truth about how she got
the van back Jeff doesn't come clean
about approaching Kevin tan at the gym
and perhaps most importantly Cali
doesn't tell them about this mysterious
older guy that she met at the bar Jeff
is honest about not being over the
affair though and Sean is honest about
what happened to Adam when Cali asks
this seems to improve their situation
for the time being but the fact that
Cali was texting with Jay planning to
meet up right before Shauna came to get
her feels like it'll come back to cause
problems I'm not sure if this is
evidence that she's been seeing him as
in he's the friend that she's been
drinking with at the park but they've at
least been talking which means he's
trying to get more information from her
to help them with the case Beyond Shauna
looping Cali in on their crimes the
thing that really hit me here was
Shauna's reaction when Jeff brought up
the fact that she was their only child
this exchange suggests that he has no
idea about the Wilderness pregnancy or
what happened to their first baby which
is another thing that might come back up
before all is said and done there wasn't
much teen Shauna in this episode but she
did reveal to the group that they had a
bear meat thief in the same way that
everyone looks surprised about the
p-bucket incident no one cops to this
and Mari tries to pin it on Coach Ben
she says that he thinks he's better than
them which is a line that does a lot of
work to show their Shame about what
happened and the growing defensiveness
and suspicions that go along with that
Ben maintains that he didn't do it and I
tend to believe him his health has
improved but that's likely linked to the
starlink soup that's it's been around
long enough that everyone's already
getting tired of it when that defends
him Mari shifts her Focus to blaming her
for the lack of fresh meat and that
expresses some righteous outrage since
she and Travis are the only ones that
are even trying to provide food Mari
smugly gives Lottie the credit for all
the meat that they've had for the past
few months and that kicks off a debate
about whether she was really responsible
for any of it there's a lot of
interesting stuff that comes up while
they go back and forth especially Vans
saying that no one that was there could
say that the bear was a coincidence
Aquila points out that the birds
appeared right after the blood dripped
on the symbol that Lottie made Ben
rightly points out that that could be a
coincidence and we see that the lines
are being drawn between the ideas of
faith and reason this is an
inevitability that plays out through
Nat's one-on-one hunting challenge but
the most surprising thing about the
whole situation is lottie's reaction she
looks much less convinced about her role
than the girls who want to believe that
she's responsible for their Good Fortune
chin and I use the word inevitable
because as their connection to
civilization deteriorates and the idea
of a rescue slips into the background
it's natural that they'll try to fill
the void that's left behind they're
desperate to survive in a situation
where most of what they know is no
longer helpful they're looking for
something to make it all make sense and
make it all feel better Laura Lee
symbolized traditional faith in religion
and she's gone Ben was an authority
figure with answers who was sidelined
through his injury and now is becoming
an outsider because he didn't partake in
their original sin of eating Jackie
Natalie and Ty make good Arguments for
the rational interpretation of things
but they haven't had good results in
helping or providing for the group you
could see why the ones who have even a
shred of willingness to believe that
someone might be able to save them are
leaning toward Lottie and some of the
mysterious things that happen around her
all of that's to say that the
competition makes sense Mari is kind of
a jerk for calling that out while she's
genuinely trying to obtain food but she
hasn't been bringing anything back and
she knows this so she recognizes that
she might not be able to succeed but
also doesn't believe Lottie can bring
anything back either so even if she
fails she can at least prove that it's
not just her and that there isn't any
magic happening on lottie's end adult
Nets trip out with Lisa makes a little
less sense and is mostly predicated on
her wanting to get lottie's keys so that
she can find out what's locked away in
her room they never make it to the
farmer's market and it's a situation
where the lie she told Lottie about
wanting to bond with Lisa is what
actually happens this is mostly due to
Lisa's mom being nasty and that visit
ends with Nat smuggling her fish out
inside her mouth which made for a
classic reveal otherwise we get some
insight into how lottie's followers see
her and in spite of the heliotrope
clothes and the rules and everything
else that's going on the process does
seem to help them to some extent and
that doesn't exactly come around to it
it's clear she's still planning on
breaking into lottie's lock cabinet but
some of the rough edges are worn down
and she does warm up to Lisa who reveals
that she was there when Nat had the gun
in her mouth and when we see Nat push
the drink away after she asks if she
still wants to kill herself it feels
like a turning point for the character
Lisa mentions that she weaned herself
off her medication which makes the fact
that Lottie was trying to get her dosage
increase seems somewhat dubious this
whole trip is kinda strange because they
made the choice of having her see
someone other than her regular doctor
although the one she does see assures
her that she's familiar with her file
the key piece of information for me here
is that Lottie hasn't had Visions for
decades she does refer to them in that
way rather than delusions or
hallucinations but then she also insists
that they aren't real and I think what's
going on here is when she says that it
sounds more like she's trying to
convince herself rather than something
she actually believes because of the
doctors switch I maybe looked at this a
little too closely I wondered if it
could be part of a vision because of the
way the doctor encouraged her to examine
what the Visions might mean but there
aren't any of the degraded video
transitions or anything else to indicate
that's what's happening it feels a
little suspect but it also works to set
up the way she's struggling with the
idea of something from the wilderness
coming back so I'm not sure if it's more
than that we'll have to wait and see
later that night when she's looking
through gratitude statements from her
followers she finds the queen of hearts
card with the eyes scratched out this
seems important and related to what
happened in the woods there's a lot of
talk of drawing cards and there was that
comment last season where they said
there were no queens in the deck and
when she sees it it wipes the smile off
her face and she grabs a knife and walks
through a tree stump that resembles the
one in the forest and cuts her Palm to
make a blood offering through tears she
says can't this just be enough please so
if you put what she said in the
therapist's office together with that
you see that she's worried about an
escalation and it's probably related to
what we see starting when she does the
same thing when she ran out of ideas
during the hunting competition she goes
to the stump where she offered up the
Bear's heart and Spills her blood the
way the episode is cut the next thing we
see is Natalie discovering the Frozen
moose in the lake which would almost
make it seem like her blood offering
worked except they aren't able to get
the Moose out of the ice and It
ultimately sinks to the bottom Lottie
wanders around bleeding and comes across
the plane that we all saw Laura Lee blow
up in back in season one when she looks
inside she finds her teddy bear Leonard
which we saw catch on fire and her gold
cross and necklace in the back on top of
a hatch that leads to a shopping mall
yeah none of this is real but it's also
notable that there is no this is a
vision transition either there is an
almost music version of the theme song
which is not to be confused fused with
the updated version that was performed
by Alanis Morissette that opened the
episode and as weird as all this is not
much happens other than she runs into
everyone at the food court including the
deceased Laura Lee but not the deceased
Jackie the show subverts your
expectations that something important is
going to happen here all that really
occurs is that Nat reminds her she's a
shoplifter and Laura Lee reminds her
that she's hungry and then helps her
snap out of it because she's really just
losing a fair amount of blood in the
snow and freezing to death it's not to
say that it's not important because
Laura Lee also showed up in the vision
she had when Travis was dying and it
does pair these two up in the same way
that Shawna and Jackie are paired I
think there's an obvious connection to
regret Shauna not going to Jackie the
night that she died and Lottie not
stopping Laura Lee from flying away in
the plane after she had that vision and
in lottie's case that may lead to her
feeling like she has to trust what she
sees in her visions and follow through
but in this case she doesn't really see
anything actionable except maybe the
whole Going Underground part and that
she doesn't immediately discover
something of use kind of reinforces what
Nat was hoping would happen from this
competition from her perspective but
since the conditions don't change it
won't dissuade the True Believers
especially because of what happens at
the end as far as Nat and Lottie are
concerned it seems to have brought them
closer together and they share a nice
moment and a good game after the others
get Lottie back to safety we know on
some level this won't last based on how
they interact 25 years later but it also
hints that if Natalie can soften up
there is something there that they can
build on there are a couple of other
things that happen that we should
probably keep track of but didn't
exactly fit in with anything else I was
talking about I mentioned that Ben isn't
as close to death as he seemed at the
end of the last episode he has another
vision of his boyfriend Paul that I
can't say for sure is a memory or a what
if I didn't board the plane fantasy see
it feels like the latter because it
looks like he's moving in but either way
this is also about regret he finds a
photo album of some of Paul's exes and
then admits that he doesn't have that
kind of History I guess this will be
part of an ongoing series of these that
we'll see week after week and I'm hoping
that it'll make more sense when we put
them all together because it's not
surprising that Ben is feeling regretful
about getting on the plane it does show
that he's in a similar headspace as he
was last week and with no new food
coming in that still makes him seem like
a possible candidate for their next meal
he's also reading a book called The
Magus which is another word for sorcerer
I never read it so I can't say much
beyond the description that says the
main character becomes embroiled in the
psychological illusions of a master
trickster which becomes increasingly
dark and serious trickster is a word
that catches my attention but I don't
see any immediate parallels in what's
happening in the story right at the
moment Mari is still hearing the
dripping sound and it's still a mystery
it appears that that it's just her and
most of the theories I've seen about
this haven't been that interesting she
gets Aquila to help her investigate the
sound then that leads to her finding a
mouse in the pantry that she decides to
keep secret I'm sure both of these
things are leading somewhere but these
two characters mainly are here to be on
lottie's side of the Divide Nat Tai
Shauna and Ben are pretty firmly on the
other side so there needs to be someone
besides van behind Lottie teen Misty
showed that none of this is set in stone
when she chose possibly eating moose
over doing nothing and how they make
their choices and how things go back and
forth will be interesting going forward
and while we're on the subject of Misty
I gotta say that this episode delivered
everything I was hoping to see last week
with Walter this feels like the exact
shot in the arm the present day timeline
needs and it was as simple as making
Walter a multi-millionaire as a result
of a traumatic head injury just about
everything that transpires between these
two is fun to watch in this episode and
it is quirky but that also kind of
distracts you from how limited Walter's
time on this planet may be now that he's
in Misty's orbit
they're all lucky to have you it's
pretty rare to have a friend who's
relentlessly gotten your back this was
the first crack in the Shell obviously
the case full of show tunes set off some
red flags but when you follow it up with
your being a yellow jacket is the least
interesting thing about you well you've
got Misty Quigley's attention all of
this still manages to feel somewhat
suspicious but it's kind of like how
even though you know Misty is a killer
you're willing to let that go for the
time being these two are perfect
together and just a blast to watch I'm
not an expert on musicals but can
recognize that if this was a prompted
deceive Misty the amount of time that
would be required to make that
believable would also serve to make
Walter as compelling of a character as
you can imagine right now every time
these two open their mouths I don't want
it to stop as far as their subplot is
concerned it's all fairly
straightforward they're on the Cults
Trail after following up on the Fanta
clue and after they fail to find them at
the farmer's market they end up getting
rooms in the night at a local bed and
breakfast and plan to wake up in the
morning and go to lottie's compound add
in the palpable chemistry that Misty
can't really indulge in because she's on
the case and that's about it but it's in
the details that make it cook it's the
way he baits her when he chooses to play
Starlight Express the strange meat
shelled breakfast taco with a dollop of
mustard the way he already has a local
BNB already scoped out the way they both
choose fake names related to mystery and
thrillers she uses lady malawan which he
definitely picks up on as a title Agatha
Christie got when she married her second
husband he uses John Lang which was a
pen name Michael Crichton used when he
was writing in medical school and it's
the will they or won't they of it all As
It Seems like if nothing else Walter
would like to make that happen as I
mentioned he's absolutely suspicious I
mean being into someone's posting so
much that a Sweeney Todd reference gets
you to borderline stalk them in real
life is by definition suspicious but he
also seems sincere up to this point the
great split screen sequence backs this
up because you see that they're
simpatico even when no one's watching
he's not putting up some front while
he's in his room and besides we know
Misty is dangerous so he might just turn
out to be a tragic figure it's weird to
root for Misty to have these new
friendships in her life while also
contemplating that neither Walter nor
Crystal will probably survive the season
I'm still very concerned about what
might happen to Steve but now Walter is
also on that list back in the wilderness
band has been keeping a map of all the
trees that sleepwalking tie has taken
her to when she integrates the location
of the trees with symbols with Ben's map
she's able to make the symbol by
connecting the points and that fails to
impress Tai van doesn't understand how
she's unable to see what's right in
front of her but is able to convince her
that they'll be able to find another
Marked Tree in the spot where the hook
would be they don't find one but they do
find another tree with melted snow at
the base similar to the one that and
Travis noticed at the end of episode one
when Van's looking at that Ty hears the
sound and when she pursues that it turns
out to be Javi this isn't surprising to
me if you've been watching my videos you
know that I thought this was coming but
it is an absolute mystery because as
I've mentioned it shouldn't have been
possible for him to survive this long
without assistance he's wearing the
exact same clothes he had on at Doom
coming and just has a blanket wrapped
around him so the elements would have
gotten to him by now Travis is also
wondering how he survived but he doesn't
answer he looks like he spooked or
possibly he's not able to comprehend
what they're asking or he isn't able to
talk it's a classic situation of
bringing up more questions than it
answers and you're also left wondering
how things will play out between that
and Travis because of the look they
share and the general sense of dread you
know she has because of her plan with
the bloody pants backfiring
unsurprisingly Mari attributes this to
Lottie as far as saying she knew he was
alive and as is the new Norm Lottie
looks unsure about how that makes her
feel this is more complicated than her
followers think at this point because
they obviously don't know about the
blood offering because they would
attribute his return to that if they did
Van adds that Tai was the one who knew
where he was and she pushes back a lot
harder than Lottie but because she was
awake when this played out it should be
hard for her to completely discount
something weird going on that also makes
the choice of cutting from this to the
reunion with adult band makes sense
because it adds to the mystery of why
they haven't talked for so long and
that's where it leaves things waiting to
hear what Javi will say back in 96 and
what van will say in the present day so
this felt like it was the best episode
of the Season as far as how it was put
together and how it moved between
stories and timelines in a way that
approached seamlessness the Shauna and
Cali story still doesn't get me very
excited and exposing their crimes to her
didn't really solve this but I did perk
up when Jeff brought up the idea that
she was their only child and I'm just
holding out hope that when this connects
back up to the other yellowjacket
stories that it'll all make sense beyond
that everything else was good and
promising to get better the Lisa and Nat
side quests felt a little out of place
at first but when that pushed the drink
away that felt like it refocused things
on her and that made it all seem worth
it plus the reveal of the fish in the
mouth after they made you 100 certain
that she was gonna grab the whole tank
that all made for an awesome moment in
the car we did need some insight into
what the average follower of Lottie
thought about her and this worked for
that but unless some of these theories
about Lisa being an important character
turn out to be true I would prefer to
see more of Nat and Lottie together
after all they have some things to work
out because that connection they formed
from the warm moment they had around the
bathtub was likely severed as soon as
hobby returned to the cabin although
adult Lottie on her own was was also
pretty fascinating this week I really
like how in the present Lottie is
worried about what might happen based on
what we're seeing unfold in the past
she's answering the blood Hive vision
and making an offering because it wants
blood but is worried that the same thing
will happen again with the therapist she
says the last time it became something
different it can't happen again and
what's up with the fact that if she
wants to leave this past behind why does
she have so many reminders of it around
her compound I looked around a little
bit today to see if other people thought
the changing therapist thing was weird
too and it seems like I'm not alone most
of what I saw was about her giving bad
advice about how to deal with divisions
which may go along with that because I
can't really see a rational reason why
they made the choice to add that detail
unless maybe this woman not upping her
dosage turns out to be a problem that's
pretty thin though this isn't a
situation where we had an established
character and they had to recast or
something like that it it's a brand new
character so why make a point of her
being a replacement it could hint at
something deeper going on but at the
same time it doesn't stand out that much
so I'm not really ready to go there yet
I'm curious to see how the mall Vision
will fit into what's happening in the
wilderness hobby did have to come from
somewhere and the melded snow around the
trees is something that they'll have to
explain the first introduction with Nat
and Travis was so inscrutable that you
could only assume that it was going to
be important and now seeing another tree
right before they find hobby confirms
that melted snow makes you think of a
heat source and since they haven't seen
anything on the surface after searching
so much of the area around the cabin you
almost have to think about something
underground especially when Lottie is
having visions with hatches a lot of the
theories have sounded somewhat
far-fetched but Javi was somewhere and
I'd say he almost had to have met up
with someone else I mean they introduced
the idea that someone was stealing bear
meat in this episode but I'm not sure
that feels like it's enough to keep him
going for that long I guess the other
route they could take would be that he
did die and then was brought back after
her blood sacrifice but if underground
bunkers and another group like law
sounds like too much then I don't know
where bringing people back to life lands
on that scale whatever it is I just hope
it's cool and I do hope Walter might
stick around based on what we've seen he
really is a good fit for Misty we know
that being accepted for who she is is
the thing that drives her as a character
and if we can take him at his word it
seems like he does that I guess the
problem might be that he knows her more
than he lets on and could even know
about what happened with Adam or Jessica
Roberts I mean the thing we know about
this character is that he's Rich enough
that he doesn't have to work he's got a
lot of time on his hands and he likes to
Snoop around in people's lives and it
did jump out to me as a mistake when she
lied to him about knowing Adam's mother
so maybe being yellow jacket is the
least interesting thing about her
because he's really into the idea that
she's a killer and wants to team up
we'll have to wait and see because I
think that is a great place to leave
things please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon